I would like to well if I could
individually hug every vancouver right
in the room I do so because as you most
of you probably know within the last day
or so we found out that Vancouverites
are the unhappiest people in Canada yeah
and if anyone from Toronto left I would
not laugh because you were this much
away from last place so I'm
coincidentally um yesterday John Haley
well one of the authors of that report
said to me when he was here at the
Museum people are happiest when working
with other people for other people and
to good purpose and I think everyone in
this room knows that whether its
sustainability or health or our own
individual happiness many of the issues
that are facing us either as individuals
or as communities they all come down to
more many of them come down to personal
connections that museum of an coover
connection is our business we are
dedicated to connecting people with each
other and also connecting people with
place and that place being obviously
Vancouver um the museum is intensifying
its its cos dedication to social
connection and civic engagement this
symposium is and is a good example of
that I'm also as some of you may know we
are opening an exhibition called a happy
show this week actually in a couple days
and this project which is developed by
Stefan Sagmeister who not sure he's in
the room but he's it's really a fearless
exploration of what makes him happy what
makes people happy and the lessons that
he's learned and after this symposium
there's going to be a reception and
we're going to take small groups in her
sneak preview ok the museum Vancouver is
very excited to be hosting this
changemakers symposium and we're
actually particularly excited by the
partnerships behind it because you know
really partnerships are everything I
think for me in trying to have impact
trying to achieve anything so we'd like
to thank the bc ministry of social
development and social innovation the bc
partners the social impact
I'm see far really who is the organizing
force behind this this project and
that's Canadian Institute for Advanced
Research and I'd also like to thank our
friends from a variety of agencies in
the City of Vancouver governments I
think their number them in the room so
at this point I'm delighted to introduce
Alan Bernstein of the Canadian Institute
for Advanced Research see far is a
unique national research organization
dedicated to creating ways of thinking
by connecting researchers from across
Canada with their international peers
see far is dedicated to helping to
connect researchers to leaders and
practice policymaking and community
initiatives and their goal is to connect
people who are able actually to put
research insights into practice dr.
Bernstein has led see far for the past
three years he's a scientist
internationally recognized for his work
in stem cell and cancer research and his
leadership positions have included
founding president of the Canadian
Institutes for health research and
executive director of the global HIV
vaccine enterprise so the bat please
welcome dr. Bernstein thank you thank
you very much Greg I'm really pleased to
be here today you mentioned the
Vancouver's ranking I read that article
as well and I was actually quite
surprised John I don't usually
contradict you because this is your area
but I happen to walk by the Vancouver
our calorie yesterday and I I counted
about 30,000 really happy people so I
think it's a sample size attribution
problem I'm really pleased to be here
with all of you today and actually a lot
of see far as board members are here i'm
not going to read them all off by name
but see far as blessed to have a
volunteer very committed passionate
board of directors who are committed to
this organization and many of them here
today i'll ask you to wave your hand or
stand up or whatever you'd like to do
but it's great that our board is here
with us today and I want to thank you
Greg and and the Museum of Vancouver for
partnering with see far to bring this
event to the museum today and like you
I'd like to thank the Ministry of Social
Development and social innovation of
British Columbia partners for social
impact for supporting this event and
introducing us actually the very active
social innovation community here in
British Columbia I think bc has probably
the most robust and innovative and
largest community of social innovators
certainly in the country see far is no
stranger to bc we have been connecting
the very best researchers in British
Columbia to the very best in the world
since our very beginning about 35 years
ago in 1980s in fact you bc has more CFR
fellows than any other university on the
planet and i think it speaks to amongst
other things the excellence of the
university and its alignment with what
our interests are on the including
issues around social interactions
well-being and happiness and then John
Hallie well I think there's a perfect
exemplar of that the government of
British Columbia has also been a one of
our most generous and
assistant partners over the years along
with the governments of canada quebec
ontario and alberta canadian
international partners individuals
foundations and corporations see far is
founded on the conviction that some of
the most exciting and important
questions of our time are best addressed
by putting together the world's very
best minds to think in new and different
ways through our unique global research
programs we create interdisciplinary
connections between the world's top
researchers